pour le printemps ces engins de chantier
laisseront place à un jardin le square
de beaufortain fait peau neuve
maurepas réaménage cet espace de 4500 m²
en lieu de vie inter générationnelle ça
rentre en perspective de l'amélioration
du cadre de vie des mauriciens avec
l'aménagement d'aires de jeu s'était
demandée notamment des aires de jeu 2
pour les plus de 1 an
donc ça va satisfaire aussi des
assistantes maternelles par exemple avec
des appareils de fitness pour adultes
mais aussi pour les personnes âgées
voilà un parcours santé qui est très
important aussi pour nous pour la les
mortuaciens qui souhaitent faire du
sport boulodrome table de ping pong mais
aussi un équipement développement
durable c'est si carré potager qui
seront mises à disposition des mots
croisiens avec un bac de récupération
d'eau pour alimenter ses six carrés
potagers coût total des travaux 600000
euros financé à 30 % par le conseil
départemental
un investissement nécessaire pour ce
quartier qui n'avait jamais connu de
transformation ici même à démarrer les
premiers coups de pioche de la
construction de la ville nouvelle
dans les années 60 sur la plaine de la
jeunesse qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
quartier de la géo et donc voilà c'est
aussi un signe fort dans le cadre du
renouvellement urbain j'allais dire de
notre ville belleville de maurepas dans
la même dynamique le groupe scolaire de
la jauge sera rénové pour la rentrée
2010 9 les squares de ré et de rouen
devrait suivre le même exemple en 2018